-Our first guest tonight,
hosts Sunday TODAY with
Willie Geist
Sunday mornings on NBC.
He also co-hosts
Morning Joe,
weekday mornings on MSNBC.
Please welcome back to the show
Willie Geist, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Nice to have you back, man.
-Hey man. How are you?
Good. You shared
a very nice moment
with me as we
were walking out.
You said your makeup
was also very bad during COVID.
-I was watching the monologue.
My first interview
I did during COVID.
I had people call me after
and saying prayers up.
You have COVID.
[ Laughter ]
-That's how bad you looked.
-That's how bad it was.
And I, like you, appreciate our
makeup artist so much more.
-Yes. Well,
you also took advantage
of both makeup and wardrobe
because the Halloween
on The TODAY Show,
this is a tradition.
This is the highest bar.
I'm going to --
This is I'm not just being
a Homer NBC guy.
-Well, here's our secret.
We have an amazing team
at The TODAY Show,
plus a group
you know well --
the SNL costume,
hair, makeup, wardrobe,
the wigs,
the whole show, so.
-Two years ago, we actually
had you on this same day,
two years ago,
you've been Tom Brady.
You upped your game
this year, my friend.
You were Harry Styles.
-I was Harry Styles. Yeah.
-And and there --
there's a photo
of Harry Styles right there.
And you're just really...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...really going for it.
-That angle.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This is, uh...
-Oh, wow. Wow.
-This is a tall
Harry Styles.
-[ Laughing ] So tall.
-So tall.
-Tall and not quite as lean
as Harry Styles.
-Now, were your colleagues
impressed?
Do you get feedback
when you show up on set
from the other
TODAY show team?
-It's a very supportive
environment
because everybody's putting
themselves out there.
-And a lot of times when you're
putting it out there
on The TODAY Show,
that out there is outside.
-Outside.
-A lot of the show is outside.
-It is.
-It is not the summer.
-No, it's not the summer.
So you first of all,
we get out there
at 5:00 a.m. to rehearse.
-Yeah.
-And then the big show
is about 8:00.
So it's, you know.
It's late October.
-Yeah.
-It's 40 degrees
or something like that.
I have a skintight jumpsuit on
with diagonal stripes.
-Yeah.
-In the commercial break,
[Laughing] Al Roker,
Al Roker came up to me
and started reading
the weather on my body.
And by that
I mean he goes,
"Ooh, it's awfully
chilly up here."
[ Laughter ]
And then he says, "And
unseasonably cool down here."
-How dare he.
How dare he.
-Isn't that mean?
-Meteorology comedy, it's done.
-Yeah, at work, it's a cliche.
-You also, you --
Look, this wasn't just costume,
you know,
again, a lot of the best people
put their best
into the way you looked.
You then matched that effort
with your dance moves.
Can we -- Can we talk
a little over this video
of what you're having here?
-Yes, let's see what you have.
Oh, Gosh.
-I mean, that's really good.
You're lip-synching.
-Is it?
-That's the lip-synching part.
So, Harry Styles...
-There's a real good
Harry Styles move right here
at the end that I.
-Yeah. You know
I see it on playback.
-There it is.
[ Laughter and applause ]
There it is.
-Really? Yeah?
I don't know.
I spent a lot of time
in the days
leading up
to Halloween on YouTube
with Harry Styles dance moves,
to the point my kids are like,
"Dad, are you still watching
Harry Styles dance?"
And I pulled out, I think,
he has three big moves.
First, we're just going
big energy like a fist pump.
-Yeah, he does the fist pump.
-And then on this song,
as it was,
I noticed he does a big
like a reverse windmill thing.
-Yeah.
-So that's number two.
And then the last one you saw
there was big on Instagram
I think, where he does like
he's in here a little bit
and he's leaned back.
And the crowd screams.
-I accidentally watched it once.
-Accidentally.
-And I feel like the algorithm
is like, hey,
you want to see that every day?
-I know.
Imagine me.
-Yeah.
-I spent two days watching.
the FBI's going
to seize my computer.
-I feel like for our
professional job
sometimes we have
to watch stuff.
I once a month,
I'd like to have a meeting
with the algorithm people
and be like,
"Hey, that's not me."
-No, that was for work.
-That was a thing for work.
-Yes, clear all.
-And, yeah, every time
I'm going to watch it.
But that doesn't mean I want you
to keep giving it to me.
-That's the thing.
That's the thing.
You reject it
and then you just lean into it.
-Yeah.
-You just accept that you can't.
-Like, I guess I am
who you are telling me I am.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, every now and then,
because this one did, I think,
maybe go a little bit
more viral than a normal
"TODAY Show" segment.
-Yeah.
Did you hear from anybody
who you realize maybe isn't
watching the show every day,
but saw it on social media?
-Oh, my gosh, I -- So my
daughter had a game yesterday.
She plays field hockey.
We go to the visiting field,
which means I don't know
the parents.
I walk in, walk past
a group of moms
and they all go,
"Hi, Harry." Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And I was like,
oh, this is my legacy.
Yeah, this is it.
-You did all this.
-This is how...
-All this work
and that's your legacy.
-It's been a long road and this
is all I'll be remembered for.
-Well, I do want to talk
to you about the other stuff
I think you should be
remembered for.
We'll be right back with more
from our friend Willie Geist.